خلينا نعطي المشاهدين معلومات عن اول ازمه
اقتصاديه في التاريخ او اول انهيار تاريخي
في الاسواق للمفارقه كانت هاي الازمه ازمه
بصل طبعا البصل الذي كان بطل الازمه
التاريخيه الاولى هو الازهار التوليد الذي
وصل سعره في النصف الاول من القرن 17 ما
يوازي مئه الف دولارات في ايامنا اليوم
على فكره كانت الاسعار تتضخم بشكل كبير
جدا وبدا الناس خصوصا في هولندا بالمضاربه
في البصل يعني حتى اصبح حاله جنون في كل
اوروبا البصله الواحده كانت تباع خمس مرات
دون ان تكون موجوده اصلا مثلا اذا عدنا
الى عام 1637 يعني هذا قراناه في التاريخ
انفجرت فقاعه البصل وحصلت اول ازمه
اقتصاديه حاده في التاريخ فقاعه بصل
يعني مهم تاريخيا والمشكله كمان رمضان
كريم قريب كل طبخاتنا العربيه بالبصل اصلا
بتحب البصل على احب واطبخوا كمان انا احبك
كمان